-Our next guest is
a wonderful actress
who earned an Emmy nomination
for her role as Shiv Roy
on the hit series "Succession."
The highly-anticipated
third season premieres
Sunday, October 17th on HBO
and to stream on HBO Max.
Here's a clip.
Oh, right.
They wouldn't send one.
[ Laughing ]
-Please welcome back to the show
and to the studio
for the first time,
Sarah Snook!
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-I am delighted to have you
here in person.
-Yeah. It's good to be here.
-I got to have you --
we Zoomed over the pandemic,
but this is so much nicer.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-Yeah. It's real life.
-It's still unnerving,
but it's in real life.
-Also nice to have you back
in New York City,
and I know you sort of
came from Australia to do press
and we were talking backstage --
you will basically have to
quarantine
when you get back to Australia
for as long as you were here.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, which is why
this is unnerving.
Being in person with anybody
right now.
-Yeah, exactly.
They're like, "Were you anywhere
with a bunch of people?"
And you're like, "Uh..."
-There's no evidence anywhere.
Don't worry about it.
-You spent some time
living in Brooklyn, yeah?
-Yeah.
-Did you like it?
-I love it. I love Brooklyn.
It's like...I don't know,
Brooklyn's like --
[ Applause ]
-Yeah, right?
It's great. I don't know.
Brooklyn's like, the fighty,
little brother to Manhattan
or like
the Australia to America.
It's like,
on the outside looking in,
but you get the better view.
-Do you think that you --
do you find everything is
sibling rivalries
now that you're on "Succession"?
-Yeah, I mean, weirdly,
I don't have much of a sibling
rivalry with my sisters, though,
so I guess so, I do.
-Are you the youngest of three?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
You know, I'm wondering --
one of the things that's so much
fun watching you guys as actors,
it's very clear that you
like each other.
Mostly because you are
being definitely mean to
people that in real life,
you care about.
-Yes.
-Is there anyone you like
being mean to the most?
-Kieran.
-Totally.
-I was gonna say, I've met
Kieran and he's lovely,
but I think he'd be super fun
to be mean to.
-Oh, yeah, but he's also
super mean to just to be fun,
you know, like, to you.
-Right.
-That's the way he shows love.
-Is it true that you guys
early on,
before you knew each other well,
had to be, like,
physical in a scene together?
-Yeah, well, we had to fight --
like, wrestle, and yeah.
I mean, this was like,
the first episode back
in the first season shooting
and we had to wrestle,
and we tried -- you know,
the stunt coordinator's there
and he's like, teaching us
how to do it properly
so we don't hurt each other,
and then finally, Kieran's like,
"Can I just slap you?
It's gonna be easier."
I was like, "Okay, sure.
For this one, fine."
And he slaps me, and there's
a sibling kick that happened,
and I just went for him.
And then he knows WWE
for some reason.
He's a tiny, little wrestler.
He's just obsessed
with watching it.
And he just knew how to
do all the holds,
so I thought I was winning
for awhile,
but then, like,
he got me up against the wall
and like, pulled me down.
-And then when you watched it,
did you realize,
"Oh, that's the take they used,
when we fully went for it."
-Yeah, 100%. Yeah.
Because you can see in my eyes,
like,
there's some little thing
that goes, "Oh, [bleep]."
It's like a little fly swat
or something.
"Get away from me."
-Do you ever,
when you have time off --
like, I know you had a big,
obviously layoff during COVID.
Do you try to
come up with things
that you think Shiv would say?
Like, Shiv terminology?
-Yeah. The thing is, though...
I mean, I found this word,
"yoga babble."
Have you heard that?
-Yoga babble? No.
-Yeah, yoga babble.
Yoga babble's like
the encompassing word
for bull[bleep], I guess.
It's like,
business world bull[bleep].
But I feel like anything in
business is yoga babble to me,
in a little way.
I feel like Business Cat when
I'm learning about
all the business things.
You know,
mergers and all this stuff.
I'm like the business cat
who does this.
You know that gif
just doing this?
-You're the extra in
the background at a computer.
-Business business business.
You don't do this anymore.
It's laptops here.
-You're very convincing.
You're very convincing
as someone who,
it's becoming clear now,
knows nothing about
the character you're playing.
-I'm an actor.
I just do what I'm told.
-Matthew MacFadyen,
your wonderful costar,
was here yesterday, and
I asked him about Brian Cox.
I'm fascinated by Brian Cox,
who I've never met.
I said, "He seems irascible,
but I'm sure he's sweet."
What's your answer to that?
-The same. Exactly.
He's irascible. No, he's lovely.
He's a big teddy bear.
He loves, you know, being
loud and rambunctious.
-We had to blur his face mask,
because this is what he wore
to the premiere last night.
It's #TeamLoganRoy,
and see if you guys can guess
what's blurred out.
[ Laughing ]
-Just so you can understand
what he was about to say.
-Yep.
-Through the mask.
-Nominated for an Emmy,
but I heard
you won another prestigious
award that I was unaware of.
-Oh. [ Laughs ]
-The Meryl Streep Acting Award.
-Yeah. Did you know about this?
-I didn't know about --
-When I was 11? What?
-Okay, so you're 11 years old.
Who gave out
the Meryl Streep Acting Award?
-My Year 6 teacher, Mr. Cornish.
I mean, he gave awards
to everybody.
Everybody in the class
got an award,
and I just happened to get
the Meryl Streep Award,
because I was really the loudest
and more performative one.
I mean, I'm sure that
there was an Einstein Award,
and I'm sure there was --
-Now, did you know at the time
this was not a real award?
Or did you go off to Year 7
being like,
"Make way for the Meryl Streep
winner."
-The queen is here.
Yeah, definitely.
Yeah, I took that home.
I still have it somewhere.
It's like,
in my collection of stuff.
-As well you should. You don't
get rid of something like that.
-No, I mean,
it was made on wood,
and I'm sure there was that
paperclip on there somewhere,
but it's still in my stuff.
-We talked about how people
were very taken with Shiv
as well as Shiv's look.
You know, she has a very
unique fashion sense
which I think people
were drawn to,
because they
love the show so much.
Halloween's coming around.
You have seen, right?
You have seen people dress up
like Shiv for Halloween.
-I have, yeah.
-That's really high praise.
-Yeah, but isn't it the easiest
Halloween costume ever?
It's just donning a red wig,
bob sort of thing
and putting on a turtleneck
and high-waisted pants.
I mean, I've got the red hair,
but I can't wear turtlenecks
or high-waisted pants anywhere,
'cause I look like I'm
a Halloween costume.
-That would be like an athlete
wearing his uniform out.
-Yeah.
-Hey, can I do -- I have
a really good Kendall Roy.
Can I do it for you?
-Oh, yes.
-Okay great. Okay.
[ As Kendall Roy ] Uh...
Dad?
-Very good.
-Thank you.
That's like, wow.
It was the spirit. Yeah,
the spirit was in the room.
Yeah, it was the pause.
-You must be so psyched
that people get to
see the show again.
I mean, we were so --
I think everybody,
after the cliffhanger of
Season 2,
was chomping at the bit
to see it again.
Do you feel great excitement
that the rest of the world
gets to see what you've done?
-Oh, yeah, totally.
And also, the anticipation
that I've been feeling,
from between working,
being shut down
and then waiting to work
and like,
wanting to know
what happens next,
finally getting to know
what happens next.
I know that anticipation,
so I sympathize.
And getting to see the episodes
finally, myself,
it's like -- I'm a big fan
of the show as well,
because we don't get to
see what Greg and Tom does.
Or we don't get to see
what Brian's doing with
all the other scenes.
I love getting to watch the show
as well.
-That's great.
I'm so excited
and I just want to tell you
this is a big deal for us.
You're the first
Meryl Streep winner
ever to be here.
And maybe even last.
-Maybe.
-Unless you come back,
which we would love to
have you back.
You guys, Sarah Snook!
"Succession" returns
for its third season
October 17th on HBO
and to stream on HBO Max.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."